yet there are not three Gods there's but
one God thus the father is Lord and by
Lord by the way if you guys don't know
what it means by Lord here by Lord it
means yahwah Yahweh Kus was used in
place of the Divine name now you guys
want me to go in depth right you guys
want me to go in depth trusting the ho
Spirit to use me to go in depth and do
so accurately and remind you of things
you've heard but again we need to hear
it repetitively until we second nature
so can I go a little in depth on this
term Lord because again I no matter how
many times we need to hear it even
though I may get tired but it's worth it
our Lord is worth it and it's worth me
repeating for you to
learn the Divine name in Hebrew is
represented by four Hebrew letters four
Hebrew
letters y
hey wow hey
okay because when the Old Testament is
written there were
no
vowel marks there were some critical
points to emphasize the correct
pronunciation of the word but the vowel
signs were pretty much added in the
500s meaning sixth Century 500 years
after birth of the Lord by a group of
Jewish scribes called the mesites
they're the ones who introduced the
vowelization so the Old Testament text
is a continental text and it had some
critical markings to help the reader
announce the word correctly but the viiz
the
viiz was introduced by a group of Jewish
scribes called the mesites in the 500s
sixth Century made the spirit perfect my
ability recall facts without any mistake
all right so in Hebrew you'll see the
words yod he W
he right but now
today in modern Hebrew it's yod he VAV
he VAV
he this is known as the Tetra grammaton
Tetra grammaton four letters this
appears over
6,800 times over
6,800 times God bless you brother may
the the Lord use me to bless you as you
bless me and may I never cause you to
stumble in Jesus name you're good
brother Jim pray for me and thank you
for putting up with my imperfections
okay over 6,800 times this name appears
okay you with me so far because I got to
give you a little background at the
nation
Creed so how do you pronounce it there
are debates Yahweh y yah yahovah I'm
convinced it's yahovah yahwah I may be
wrong let's agree to
disagree the one reason why I've now
shunn from using Yahweh I just heard
recent evidence from multiple sources
independent sources now they may be
calling from the same Source but I've
heard several people now let me tell you
how Academia works you may have three
people independently from one another
sharing the same fact not realizing all
three are getting it from one source so
I may say something that Protestant
believer says elsewhere and then Jim
says somewhere else so you have now
three independent voices saying the same
thing but you may not realize that even
though we are independent voices so I
say something and unbeknownst to me
Protestant says the same thing and
unbeknownst to him I said the thing he
said and then Jim comes along and we're
not aware that all three of us are
saying the same thing that's because
we're getting it from the same source so
this is the danger of Academia you may
think you're getting multiple
independent Witnesses when in reality
all those Witnesses are calling from one
source and that Source may be
wrong you want me
there you understand how scholarship
works so you may think you're getting
for four or five different independent
voices but in reality all those voices
got it from one source and they took
that source as gospel truth and that one
source that
then caused
multiple
independent
voices to agree is
faulty want me there so keep that in
mind with that said I've been
researching the evidence for the correct
denunciation of the name and one
particular sermon I heard argues that
there's actually evidence from the
church fathers don't ask me the name of
the church father because I can't recall
off the top of my head I'll go back to
my notes that the word Yahweh was
actually used by the Samaritans the
pronunciation Yahweh comes from the
Samaritans and the evidence shows that
Yahweh was identified as the god Jupiter
by the Samaritans in order to appease
the Romans so they could live at
peace right so that the Samaritans
started using the term Yahweh but
identified Yahweh with the god Jupiter
in
order to appease Roman sensibilities so
that they wouldn't be persecuted
if that's true then that means Yahweh
originates from Samaritan worship but
then the samarit Samaritans became
syncretistic where they then collapsed
Yahweh with
Jupiter and that's why there are some
Scholars who say do not use the word
Yahweh that is a
bastardization of the Divine name and
the earliest evidence for that
enunciation is from the Samaritans who
then identified Yahweh with the god
Jupiter everyone with me there am I
boring you with these details guys and
again I'm trusting Spirit to enable to
recall these facts
correctly now i' I see some brothers
confirming what I'm saying so that means
they've also researched this thank you
guys fact check me correct me because I
don't want to be mistaken right so
that's why I don't like to use Yahweh
anymore because once I discover that I
don't like to use the word
so yaho right yaho yahwah yahovah I'm
more comfortable with that now coming
back to the issue let's let me tie it in
with the word Lord you will not find in
the extent Greek copies of the New
Testament a
single use of the four letters yod w you
do find in Revelation 191 revelation
19:1 1 and verses 3 and 4 and verse 6
Revelation 19 verse1 Revelation 19: 3
and 4 and verse 6 the compound word
allelu yep exactly the way I like you
the way God bless you I
hope stumble you you don't cause me to
stumble because when people put too many
comments sometimes it caus me to
discombobulate but I'm enjoying your
comments you're helping me okay in
Revelation 191 in Revelation 19 Verse 3
and 4 in Revelation 19:6 John in the
spirit hears inhabitants of Heaven shout
Allelujah the Greek transliteration of
Hallelujah this is the only time you
find the form of the Divine name in the
New Testament
allelu there the word yah is
y allelu and Allelujah comes from
Hallelujah Hal meaning praise be to yah
job are you guys aware it
is you see why I go very slow because
there's too much meat to unpack and I
want to thank you and I praise the Lord
Jesus for you and the Lord bless you and
help me to love you and be used by the
spirit to build you up because if you
were not here you guys were not here I
wouldn't be teaching and if I'm not
teaching I wouldn't be forced to have to
constantly recall these details so
you're a blessing to my life and I thank
you and the Lord Lord be your reward
it's right there
allelu Greek transliteration of the
Hebrew
hallelu there yah y the abbreviated form
of the Divine name yah if you want to
say Yahweh that's up to you you know if
you want to say it I'm not going to
condemn you for it okay so you clear but
as far as the four letters y w not a
single time is it ever used in the Greek
New Testament so what did the inspired
authors of the Greek New Testament
use okay thank you TM we can pronounce
it yah some like to do it yahovah
because the wow has become VAV today but
let's not condemn them T TM cross pulse
let's agree to disagree you know they're
are brothers and you know we're their
brothers you know okay what they used
was instead is Kus
Kus anytime the New Testament quotes an
Old Testament passage where the Divine
name appears they use in place of it the
word Kus which is the word for
Lord so
then in Aramaic it would be
Mar in Hebrew it would be Adon or Adonai
early on the Jews started using the word
Adonai in place
of Y W Adonai
in place of
Y so Greek Kus Lord Hebrew Adon or
Adonai that's the word they chose in
Aramaic and go in Latin would it be
Dominos the word for Lord now guess what
it would be in Arabic guess what it' be
in
[Laughter]
Arabic guess what it be in
Arabic so when the Quran
says is the Arabic word for Lord that's
why in your Arabic Bible you'll find
that the word for Yahweh is
rendered R A or
Rabb right there you go so when the
Creed says now here's something many of
you may have not known maybe K and all
of you did not know when the Creed says
to you thus the father is Lord
here they're saying thus the father is
yahwah
yahwah so when you see it in Greek or
Latin or English you're thinking oh the
father is Sovereign yeah but it means
more than that they're using the word
Lord in place of the Divine name
yahwah you put me
there you you with me there free bird I
know I appreciate you brother but help
me to help you just stay focused so now
let me give you the meaning of this thus
the father is yahwah the son is yahwah
the holy spirit is yahwah yet there are
not three yahwah there's but one
yahwah you guys got it thank you brother
jaman I guess you're a Syrian God bless
you brother you with me there so what is
actually saying is father son and spirit
all of them are Israel's Covenant God
yahwah
yahovah we got
that that's what it's
saying now does the bible teach that you
better believe it